all right I was born in UCLA Medical
Center
I grew up primarily in the San Fernando
Valley all throughout
um my mom and dad both were in the
throes of heroin addiction so we moved
all over the place it was really
unstable
we generally migrated to like wherever
the drugs were and
at this time to stay I don't know if I
was naive or
they were just good at hiding it but I
didn't understand what was going on
you know I recall
as a child like playing Go Fish and
seeing the guy who I'm playing with like
nodding out in front of me I remember
knowing something was off with my mom my
dad was very rarely around
but I didn't know it was the drugs so I
began to develop like this sense of of
like less than you know uh all they knew
was a child was like my mom was not
showing up for me
um she's out in the streets she's
chasing drugs she's doing what she has
to do to maintain it and I had no sense
of what addiction was at the time so I
took everything like extremely personal
my dad's not here my mom's around so I I
started feeling worthless and I started
to develop these feelings of less than
I'm not enough if your own mother and
father don't want you like [__] there's
something like seriously wrong with you
you're defected some way and and I began
like nurturing these feelings I would
spend a lot of time alone
um mostly through music that was like my
only Outlet at the time that made me
feel good was music and I used to play
basketball
and I like throughout the majority of my
childhood I nurtured these feelings of
your mom and dad don't want you
then then you're worthless there's
something wrong
I was going primarily to private school
at nine at nine years old
um I don't remember the situation I know
it involved drug use prison mom and them
getting arrested but my grandparents
picked me up and they adopted me they
ultimately the process took about a year
but my grandparents took me in at eight
years old
my mom could no longer raise me in any
kind of capacity anymore
um
and I remember like going through the
adoption process with my grandparents
you know lawyers and judges and social
workers and I remember thinking in my
head like none of my friends at school
have to go through this just to have
somewhere to live
so I I again like on top of these like
terrible feelings I was already
nurturing now I'm developing like a
resentment for like Society because I
don't feel a part of it and I'm starting
to hate like everybody for that so I'm
like I'm acting out in class like I
start to steal things
um
and I remember like one specific day I
don't remember the context of the
conversation I'm sitting down in the
hallway it's between my room and the
bathroom and my grandfather's on the
phone he's on the phone with a social
worker and I remember him using the
phrase
we have to take them Brian doesn't have
anybody else
and
I get goosebumps just
thinking about that today that was the
moment the world lost me
I remember in that moment thinking okay
now you guys are only taking me because
you have to
this is what I'm telling you this is not
the reality this is what I'm saying
inside of my head so my mom doesn't want
me my dad's not even around enough he
doesn't care about me my grandparents
are only taking me in so at this point
I'm 19 years old
I'm a kid that's dying for acceptance
I'm a kid that's dying for love I'm a
kid that's dying for attention so
I start seeking it out
and my grandparents live in the suburbs
in the San Fernando Valley
and a nice neighborhood they're sending
me to a nice school so externally
everything's great everything looks good
but inside like I'm dying inside
I [__] hate Brian James I want to be
anything other than Brian James I can't
stand him because Brian James is a piece
of [__] his own mom don't want him his
own dad don't want him
his grandparents have to take him I
heard that phone call this is this is
the narrative that I'm like I'm telling
myself
so I go looking for that stuff and I'm
listening this is the age of like this
is 88 87 uh you know NWA is coming out
like gangster raps coming in you know
colors is on TV and I become fascinated
with these shows and I'm watching them
and what fascinated me was like the
sense of brotherhood like they called
each other family in the music and you
know there's the jewelry and the money
which was like super intriguing to me
but I I was looking for the family thing
and the love these are the things these
are the needs that I had at the time and
I thought gangs was the answer to all
that
I thought that was the answer to all my
problems so I started sneaking out at
night and riding my bike to the other
side of Sepulveda where
um you know more of like gang
neighborhoods in in those type of areas
and spending time
um just hanging around
like in that culture like studying
observing and getting that attention
that that I was dying for and
immediately almost around the same time
the drugs came
and I was always scared of drugs because
I I knew they played a role in my family
like heroin had consumed my family tree
at that point so I was scared of them
but
you know in my mind you know I'm telling
myself like I need these to function the
first time was the drink you know I I
drank I I pounded a 40. that was a day
and I woke up the next morning covered
and throw up covered a vomit sick with
one thought on my head
that made me feel so good I need more of
that I need more of that and I think I
drank for like the next three weeks then
I met marijuana smoking marijuana smoked
that every single day non-stop till I
met meth like it was just one thing
after the next by this point
um I'm 16 years old I'm using meth every
day I'm using alcohol like people would
say hey Brian what was your drug of
choice my drug of choice was more that's
what I tell them I'll pretty much do
more of whatever will disconnect me from
how I'm feeling because I want to live
in this fantasy world of you know these
are my homeboys and my homegirls and
they're gonna die for me
um and everything I did
for them you know we call it put it in
work whether it be a shooting whether it
be jumping somebody
whether it be stabbing somebody you get
this amazing pat on the back that says
that's right homeboy good job and I
[__] lived for that I lived for that
that soothed and filled every need I had
I believed that was the love like I
believed I had found the love that I was
looking for
so the drugs quieted my fears the drugs
and externally
um the gang life it it fulfilled every
need that I had
it was
um
I was almost 17. this is at the height
of my addiction uh when I'm on the
streets
um I'm not going home I'm up for nine
days at a time I'll sleep two days go
again my whole life was fully committed
to the gang I wasn't going home to my
grandparents house I hadn't seen my mom
in some time she's going through her
struggles as well
um we went to a party the reason we went
to this party is to celebrate my release
from juvenile hall I got out of juvenile
hall two days early and we go to this
party
so I go to the party and you know they
want to search us to go into the back of
the party and immediately the gang
bravado the whole image and uh you're
not gonna tell me you guys are searching
us like we're walking through
and granted you know we had weapons on
us too that we didn't want to get caught
so we're already you know going in in
full you know gang mind state I'm a bad
dude still this is all things that I'm
telling myself inside my head
we walk through in an altercation occurs
shortly after about 10 minutes after
inside the party
with um
with a with an opposing gang
and
it was a little scuffle maybe a couple
punches through it and it quickly got
separated
so I remember thinking like damn like
like I'm literally out two days you know
like I'm down for all this but this is a
little early like I I just got out so I
remember saying let's leave so we left
and we're jumping in the car we're
Caravan and there's probably about five
six car loads at the time maybe maybe
about 20 of us and there were probably
about 30 of them in there
so as we're driving away I'm literally
in the back seat we're turning the
corner and we see a huge fight break out
and
it's second nature for me at this point
like um
there's no thought I reached under the
seat where I was at I grabbed the knife
and I ran to the scene of the fight wow
what was happening it it was just it is
a backyard party in the 90s there's
chaos everywhere there's people fighting
I remember seeing a guy punching my
friend he's on top of him I ran behind
him I'm slightly intoxicated at this
time and I remember with my left hand
I'm left-handed I just swung like a
round house with a knife as hard as I as
I possibly could
and it hit this man
um under his left armpit
as I sit here now I can still
remember the sound you know there's like
a
like a release of wind you know
and um
as soon as I did it I ran I turned
around and ran
um as I left um I guess another one of
my homeboys or two or more went in and
stabbed him a couple times as well
the next morning
I didn't know what happened you know I
remember I went to my girlfriends that
night I had blood on my shoes
um you know I took the knife I threw in
the backyard I took my shoes I threw
them in a trash can all my clothes I
changed my clothes not knowing what
happened
and I went to church it was Sunday I
went to church it was my grandparents
that day
and I remember looking in the Metro
paper like did somebody die I you know I
called my friend on the phone he wasn't
home so I I didn't know what happened so
we're driving home from church uh with
my grandparents and as soon as we turned
the corner to my grandparents Street I
see Channel 7 I see Channel 11 a bunch
of like news channels and then the whole
row is the whole Street's lined with
cops
I go damn I go drive pop that's what I
used to tell my grandpa he says man I
can't Brian like they're all looking at
us
so uh we pulled into the driveway I'm
surrounded in my driveway by 20 cops
they do a felony arrest on me and um
they take me to I'm a juvenile so they
take me to Foothill police station in
the San Fernando Valley
put me in there um I had been in and out
of juvenile hall my whole life so I kind
of knew the process they're going to
come in and and threaten me and make me
sit for a while but as soon as they came
in
um they said you're done this time
you're done you're going Folsom San
Quentin this is we're going to spend the
rest of your life that dude died last
night and everybody told on you
and
and I can't really
identify a feeling at that moment I just
remember stealing myself for okay this
is the moment where
you be a good gang member you hold your
mud you keep your mouth shut and you
don't say [__] to them
so they came in and I said I wasn't
there I wasn't at the party I didn't do
it and at this time I'm feeling No
Remorse I'm full blown I'm entrenched in
my addiction I believe as a gang member
like this is my duty I'm not part of
regular Society I'm from the subculture
my allegiance is to my gang the drunk
the drugs that I've been doing like
constantly for like the last year have
totally numbed like any feelings I have
like
they used the word monster in court and
and I would say that's accurate
description of who I was at the time
so they saw that that I'm not saying
anything so their attempt to break me
the officers handcuffed me they walked
me around the corner my grandparents
just outside of a wall where they
couldn't see me and they go listen and
they went and told my my grandparents
were right there they said um
he's not going home today he's getting
charged for murder
and my grandparents broke down and that
was their goal to attempt to try to
break my spirit to to begin talking but
as I said man I was so numb and
at the time like nothing was Untouchable
in my core it was just a it was I was
ugly inside it was dark and it was cold
so I went to juvenile hall
um
I went through the court system they
would not allow me to plead guilty
when I went into juvenile hall to my
arraignment the judge said how do you
plead I said guilty because if I'm
guilty as a juvenile I get out when I'm
25. if they try me as an adult I die in
prison I never get out if convicted of
the crime and they charged me with
second degree murder and assault with
great bodily injury
the judge would not allow me to plead
guilty to say no you can't plead guilty
you have a fitness hearing to see
whether or not we're going to try you as
an adult
how do you plead I said guilty and they
got mad at me I ultimately I was not
allowed to plead guilty I went to court
the next day they tried me as an adult
so now I'm going to adult Court
and I was facing uh the sentence was 50
to life
which whether it's one to life two to
life if there's a letter that letter L
at the end of your sentence in the 90s
you're dying in prison there nobody's
going home at that time
so I went to um I started going to adult
Court it took about a year and a half I
ultimately went to trial
trial took a week and a half
um the crime happened in a house party
so the Witnesses were lining up around
the street
I went for a self-defense
and during the trial I remember
seeing the guy's girlfriend
get up on the stand and
just talk about like the pain and the
suffering that that the family was going
through
I learned about this man
this man was he was a good man if
I had known him in another circumstances
uh we I think we could have been best
friends
I
this is something that I figured out
years later at the time
it's disgusting for me to say this but I
was proud of what I had done
you commit a murder for a gang that's
the ultimate Pledge of Allegiance like
you're that guy now
you know I immediately became that guy
because I told him like I I told you I'm
all in on this right here
so I I was really cold it wasn't until
years later that I read the transcripts
of of my trial
that uh that that I came to understand
these things but
they ultimately found me guilty of
second-degree murder
and they give me 15 to life for that and
the assault with great bodily injury
um four years for that and I got one
year for the night so I ended up with 20
years to life
and I was 17 years old at that time
I went back to the county jail that
night and um
again like as insane as it sounds even
to me right now there was like such a
sense of Pride like I just took a life
since
for my gang
and you know I remember I got a couple
tattoos in there at the time they were
doing in the county jail was to pick
tattoos
hook up like a staple and they'd make
the ink and you know I I had got a 13
behind my ear and the sfe back here
but inside
this is the truth as I you know I'm
walking around and people like damn this
this dude is with the business this is
that the truth of the fact is inside I
was nothing but a scared ass little punk
kid who just wanted to be [__] loved
who would have done anything for love I
would have sat and spun if you would
have patted me on the back and say good
job
this is what I've learned in in the
latter years of my life you know as I
sat for I did 29 years in prison as I
sat for
about 26 of those asking myself 25 of
those asking myself why the [__] am I
doing what I keep doing
and the majority of my time was spent
inside most of my time was in a level
four maximum security so the bulk of my
life was spent in a box
with with nothing to do but think
and and and and try to understand myself
the first 20 of those years were spent
using drugs
um I did heroin
my first year in prison
there was a riot that took place
um
I got caught slipping during that Riot
and I was stabbed 27 times this is
probably about my eighth month in prison
and that put a fear in me and an anxiety
in me that um I could only
have coped with through heroin this is
what I told myself
you know I went and got some heroin and
I did it and immediately when I did it
it's like all my problems were like
bagged up and just thrown out the window
I wasn't a lifer you know I wasn't the
the piece of [__] kid whose mom and dad
didn't want him whose grandparents had
to take them you know it it like
bolsters this pride of that you're in
prison for murder like I really thought
like like
like I was a good dude like doing some
good things like I was an honorable
person you know
and um that's what the heroine did for
me and I and I remember that and I think
he [__] I found the answer to all my
problems I can do this life sentence
with this heroine
and it was great for about the next two
times until it turned on me
then my attitude is changing I don't
feel good about myself I use it and now
I'm wallowing in self-pity
and now I need it you know and I end up
getting getting strung out on it I used
it every day for six months and I tried
to stop and the pain of the withdrawals
because drugs are are plentiful in
prison you know anything you're looking
for just like these streets out here
you'll find it if you have the money and
I end up getting strung out on heroin
and I went in that Circle of of going on
these three four month runs going on
lockdown going through the withdrawal of
like two weeks I I went in that Circle
probably damn near for about 19 years
while involved in in the politics of the
yard and involved in you know trying to
make a name for myself and the things
that I did when I came to prison the
same issues that plagued me that led to
my incarceration like I hadn't addressed
none of that stuff
so prison it didn't do anything for me
all it did was introduce me to more
Elite gang members and more
sophisticated criminals and for a kid
dying to learn and and level up in that
world like I I couldn't have asked for a
better place
too you know I spent all my time on the
yard just watching observing thinking
I'm learning things that I'm growing
which today I have come to understand
especially in the moments where I'm
alone where I'm quiet
those traumas come back to haunt you
later in life
like I I still can visualize things that
I've seen circumstances that I've been
in people that I've met like the
boogeyman is real like I met some of the
hardest toughest strongest most
intellectual men probably in California
you know scary people
so I I spent my life
on those yards
and ultimately I was put away in a
security housing unit it's called the
shoe
I did um sometime in Pelican Bay shoe
and I did some time in Corcoran shoe I
did eight years in Corcoran shoe the
last time
and which basically
they take you off the main line because
they say you have an influence over
other inmates like if you're being a
good gang member and doing what you're
supposed to do that's where you end up
um
and it was in there during that time it
was in 2011 I went out to a visit it's a
one hour visit it's behind glass back
there it's a rough life
and
my mom came it was supposed to be my mom
and my grandma my grandma used to come
every weekend my mom would come every
weekend and I I tell my mom Hey where's
Nanette
and I remember my mom
again I I can see it perfect like there
was a Flinch on her face and she started
crying she told me that my grandmother
died and this was unexpected
my grandmother is Sheila Sheila Mary
James she's she's the greatest thing
that's ever happened to me in my life
um
I wasn't ready for that you know I
wasn't ready for that
and I dropped I hit the floor I hit the
floor right there I
like I didn't know what to do and 45
minutes later after telling me James
Ryan visits over backed up handcuffed
and they just put me back in the cell
what I went through in the in the
following 30 days alone inside that cell
because I was single cell like I I can't
I can't even put words to it like I
suffered
immensely so bad but like even my
teardrops were like bigger like I cried
almost for like two weeks straight and I
remember
it was probably about the first week
when
okay well my when I found out this was
New Year's Eve and and I'll never forget
that night I don't like telling this
story but
um you know I think it's important
I'm sitting in front of the TV on New
Year's Eve I just found out that my
grandmother had died and I'll never
forget it's 11 36 because it was Ryan
Seacrest and Nicki Minaj were on the TV
when I told myself I'ma [__] kill
myself right now
I I can't do it I can't do it without my
grandma and in the shoe a lot of people
are killing themselves they hang
themselves
um
from Vince or or they they take drugs to
overdose because
um it's one of the cdcr uh weapons in
their belt uh torture was to lock people
inside there and never let him out
and I remember thinking uh like I gotta
go I gotta do this I'm looking at my
body I'm covered in tattoos
I have scars from the Damage Done from
Needles
and inside my mind I'm still running
this same Narrative of this piece of
[__] kid who who nobody wants them like
that I've constantly told myself this
over the years
and I remember I closed my eyes you know
I was raised my grandparents raised me
in a Christian home so suicide was like
you you're gonna end up going to hell
you're not going to go to heaven so I
remember saying a prayer
like
making a deal with God like let me get
this last one you know I I got to go
with Nana
and I closed my eyes and I you know I
didn't have an epiphany there were no
Bright Lights nothing major happened but
when I opened my eyes
I decided to put my death off for a
couple days I was going to kill myself a
couple days later
and in the space of those couple days
I came up
with this idea that I'm going to try to
figure out how to change myself because
this [__] ain't working no more by this
point I'm [__] 30 years in the game
I've been arrested you know I I
I've been out for 200 days now
I I filled out like I did a like a mock
job application that word said felonies
you know I wrote all of them and I
literally have like you name it armed
robbery all the way up throughout
juvenile all the way up to and including
the murder charges
and I just was not happy anymore and it
was either die or become somebody new
now once you have a desire to change as
I did you need the tools to do it
there's nobody around me everybody
around me as [__] up if not more
[__] up than than I was
by that point my mom had gotten clean
she had some clean time and and she sent
me the Big Blue Book of n a and I just
started reading through it and I was
like holy [__] like this is my biography
like these people know me like they're
literally telling my story it started
there
um you know I tell people too it's a
funny story I didn't know how to act
civilized I know how to function
perfectly in a gang culture but in a
civilized I used to watch Gray's Anatomy
to see how they dealt with life problems
and made me try to like imitate
um but I was starving for something
different
I changed the music I listen to I
changed the shows I listened to and it
was about a four year process
for me to evolve into someone that I can
look in the mirror and be like
half-assed proud of myself
I got my GED in there
and this is in cdcr
um
California Department of Corrections and
Rehabilitation
they push back against change it's it's
it's not in their best interest for for
prisons to empty out
so I had to fight to actually
get therapy and get self-help groups to
start answering these questions that
that I needed
why did I become this game ever like why
why do I need drugs to feel good like
why can't why am I having conflict with
every person around me everywhere I go
like I was dying for these in
the moment came when I'm walking back in
and at this point
finally I'm out of the shoe we had a the
30 000 people took part in a hunger
strike in California
um in protest of the shoe conditions
which
um allowed us me being one of
the inmates to get out of the shoe and
back into the general population where
you have access to programming in school
so I'm out back in the general
population and I'm open to new
experiences hope I'm trying to learn
things and I walked in and I saw
positive change dog programs sign up on
the wall and I'm thinking we're in
Corcoran level four like this is
probably the most treacherous yarn in
California at this time like they're not
gonna let no [__] dogs onto this yard
but I'm open to things now like I'm
trying to be a different person and
think different I sign my name
I'll be damned if a month later
this man walks onto the yard with a pit
bull
uh Zach scout who's one of my great
mentors and friends today and I picked
my the first dog
that I've touched in like 25 years I got
down and and I ran my hand across his
fur back and forth and I can only
describe that like as a spiritual
experience for me at this point
after you know so many years in there
just to have an animal like with that
compassion he said the program's coming
next month and you're in
so the following month uh they got
together the 20 of us that were in the
program they brought seven dogs
they they intentionally pair you with
someone who's like virtually your
opposite
I got paired with a
a guy from Compton
um an active gang member from from Pyro
from Lotus Park pyro probably about
eight years my junior they said you
Brian and de Dante you guys are partners
and and you're gonna raise this dog
together now I had seen this guy around
but we never talked you know he he was a
soldier for what he represented and I
was a soldier for what I represented and
the only reason for us to talk is like
some kind of political to settle
something to deal with something other
than that it was just like a like a pure
cold respect so I had seen him around so
we started training this dog and he said
hey I got to go to school in the
afternoon you mind watching him in the
morning I said yeah I got kitchen I work
in the kitchen afternoon you got him
then so we'd start working together
and we start talking about our families
and like
while raising this dog and making
connections so
to bring it all together with with that
program this guy who was my virtual
opposite who we should have never been
friends became my best friend he's my
best friend today he pulled a year
earlier than me and we spend time
together we work together
and I had a I had a moment
during that dog program
as I was I used to get up every morning
I would run five laps with my dog
the love the acceptance the belonging
everything that I had been searching for
my entire life in gangs and drugs in the
streets and all kind of destructive
Behavior this dog gave it all to me
I I get a sense of belonging when when
the pack of dogs accept me as them
every day my dog's sitting there eyes up
looking at me tail wagging what are we
gonna do today
it's it's a love that I've been
searching for my entire life it it
fundamentally changed me who I am as a
person being involved in that dog
program
and not only did I learned a work ethic
um you you gain a sense of compassion
and empathy when you're working with
another animal and this transfers on to
my other relationships with people my
day-to-day relationships with my family
so every area of my life improved
I got clean and sober
the last time I put a needle inside my
arm
was August 10 2016.
it was the last time I ever used drugs
the dog program
came two years later
I had another opportunity because
um of good behavior in prison
and I had 35 rule violations what they
call 115 write-ups
um you know I had court cases but as I
said after my grandma's death something
something changed so I had an
opportunity to go to a level three which
was a lower level this place had College
so many self-help groups I spent three
years there fully immersed in in trying
to understand who I am why I did what I
did
um
I developed a sense of empathy and
remorse for my crime
today my Victim of my crime like I
understand
he was entirely undeserving of that like
he did nothing to deserve that it was
all me 100 me that [__] story I
should tell myself or he knew what he
signed up for if the roles reversed I'd
been in the grave and he'd be that's a
bunch of [__] right there that's
[__] you know
that's that fake [__] story that us
as gang members tell ourselves that
we're putting it in work it's not
putting in work you're taking the life
of a human being
you're not putting in work like you're
you're beating up somebody's son
you know you're hurting somebody's
daughter you can fancy it up in in
whatever kind of language you want and I
get it I I don't I don't judge anybody I
did it because you have to survive you
have to tell your mind something
but I've evolved past that thinking and
I remember
I would like to share a moment I I did a
it's called healing a dialogue three
mothers came in all three of their sons
had been murdered by gang violence and I
sat across from these women and they
told me their experience
what they went through
I could never possibly be the same
person again after hearing that and I
told them mine and I took and they and
they go what's the hardest part for you
in dealing with that and I said it's
forgiving myself like
I've managed to separate myself from
gangs I managed to get clean and sold
but the fact remains like a mother had
to close a casket on her son because of
me that's always there in the back of my
head like how can I forgive myself these
three women stood up right there with
tears in their eyes that said we forgive
you they circled me they wrapped their
arms around me and they hugged me
and we [__] sobbed together for like
a half hour right there
my life was never the same I I made a
commitment that night that under no
circumstances would I ever use violence
again
to solve my problems
um
and I was going to do everything I can
to honor the life that I took because
For Better or Worse our stories are
forever intertwined
um you know I I exploded in his world
and I took his life from him so I owe
him that
um I think about him every single day
he's he's what drives me every single
day to do the work that I do in the
community and at work and mentoring
youth
beautiful story thank you